Speaker 1: Why don't we go to let's
go to Boris from Denver. Boris,
what's going on in Denver these days?
Speaker 5: And it's just really called. Oh,
OK, let's start here and there, but not too much.
I wanted to ask you, you been doing some reading
for Black History Month and I was curious. I have
an answer to this. I think you would agree with,
but I was thinking these days
of Martin Luther King was around
with the right try to smear him as being too woke.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God, of course. Oh, wow. Yeah,
absolutely. You know, now you see many Republicans
now sort of slickly try to appropriate themselves
of Martin Luther King and say, you know, we we
love the ideals of they'll list a few people.
They'll be like Lincoln and Reagan and Martin
Luther King or whatever they would be smearing
Martin Luther King as a hoax or socialist. And
I mean, yeah, without a doubt, without a doubt.
Speaker 5: Yeah, and the thing that really drives
me crazy is a lot of them, like I've even seen the
new governor of Virginia. They try to quote him
when they pass a lot of these anti critical races.
Yes. Yes. If he as if to suggest that Martin
Luther King was opposed to a critical race theory,
and he was just like an American loving person
who just thought, Oh, America's is just a little
flawed, but it's a fundamentally great country
and all that. But they ignore when he said,
like, America is racist and all that. And one
other thing I wanted to ask about this Do you
think that? Could you see a future, I seriously
can't see one where they will try to smear him
many ways when, like his files, get released in
twenty twenty seven and the FBI files show that
he maybe was involved with there allegations that
he that he didn't stand up to a friend that was
raping a woman or something like that. He was like
casually, he was like in the room as some woman
was getting raped and he didn't do anything about
it or something like that. Listen, I've never
Speaker 1: heard that before, so I want
to be. I don't know anything about that.
I couldn't possibly make any predictions
about that. I want to be. I just I've
not heard that. I couldn't comment on that.
Speaker 5: OK, well, I've seen there was like
a report that came on a not too long and probably
a few years ago. Yeah, I saw Gavin McInnes there
on his show and even Tucker Carlson tried to cover
it, and I think they were just trying to like. I
just felt like it was the start of what I see 10
years from now. The right is going to completely
portray Martin Luther King as this bad person.
Speaker 1: Yep, I think I mean, they'll do both
things. They they will attack Martin Luther
King when it's convenient and they will
take credit for Martin Luther King when it's
convenient. They're already kind of doing it.
Speaker 5: Yeah. OK, last thing for get off, do
you have any plans or would you be opposed to
going on back on during this podcast?
Speaker 1: I have no. I've not been
invited. I would go back on any time.
Speaker 5: OK. I'd love to see you back on there,
hopefully helping, of course, correct. Thank you.
Speaker 1: I would love to do it. All right. Thank
you so much for the call.
Very much. Appreciate it.